this is not what I expected there were a
lot more knives and heads but not
actually in heads and Invincible toy
robot armies than I suspected this
chapter would contain but I suppose The
Narrative Falcon Hunter Hunter is just
so thick that you can't accurately peer
into the next chapter or even the next
page of the current chapter Invincible
toy robots can pop up at any time and we
really have a lot of cool known
abilities in this chapter more so than
you may have registered because we focus
in heavily on two new abilities but
there are actually Four before stepping
into that though chapter 399 picks up in
the Sinister saw room where we get a bit
more of that Togashi trademark character
showing they're working out there's
about two pages of speculation between
Nobunaga and Henry regarding well
regarding what's actually happening
Nobunaga suspects that the victims they
force through the doorway were actually
potentially in League with the Haley
family but we know that to not be true
because the Haley family they don't
really associate with any non-haleesians
in fact hilariously it's much more
likely that the people that the troop
fed into the Hailey were members of the
other mafia families or Associates but
what this Soul builds up to is a very
nice bro moment between Nobunaga and
Henry with the former lamenting his
potential mistake and therefore walking
into an even worse trap than suspected
however Henry's just like bro no that
that was not your mistake in fact it
probably wasn't even a mistake at all
and it's just such a weird dynamic to
have popped out of nowhere in the space
of a few minutes these two have formed a
fully functional friendship to something
more Sinister though this isn't actually
featured in the chapter but the author
comment in weakly Shonen Jump by
togashi's assistant made me took a
little bit of a closer look at the
dissection room because the assistant
stated that when they actually decided
what was going to be on that page he
felt quite ill and uncomfortable which
I'm betting all has to do with the
washing machine tumbling away them with
that like very ominous dark liquid that
is almost certainly blood and the
washing machine itself might even be a
function of someone's ability to dispose
of all of the of all of the leftover
meat although funnily enough it does
actually seem to clean clothing because
there's a drying rack to the side with
all sorts of very pristine shirts and
pants pencil nicely pressed and ready
for wearing which I assume were from the
Haley victims but it's uh it's a strange
and disturbing room and I'm really glad
that we didn't spend a lot of time there
and where we ended up was certainly less
than expected this was a very solid
atmospheric flip by Togashi setting up
this dirty bloodied Sinister environment
only for us ultimately to end up in a
brightly lit family room with a bunch of
people just sitting chilling hanging
whatever it is that the people do
together with that said I was still very
much on guard at first the 180 flip just
had me thinking that this whole thing
was a Hayley trap and they were putting
on an act and I don't think I can be
blamed for thinking that way especially
with all of the theatrical and
performative language that's been used
across the last two chapters like there
was a lot of talk in 398 about setting
up a nen stage and in this one the Haley
family were having a discussion about
music performers and band Dynamics on
stage which seemed a bit random like we
were listening in on co-workers just
desperately trying to fill time on break
I will say that this conversation is
anything but random and I don't think
this is intentional on the part of the
characters but what they're talking
about here is almost certainly togashi's
allegory for the Haley Family itself
because there's a lot of debate about
whether it's more important to be
different and unique or whether it's
more important to act as a cohesive
group to blend together and homogenize
which is exactly what's happening within
the family right now you have certain
members going down the path of wanting
to be different and doing their own
thing whilst others are prioritizing the
the lack of a better term family Dynamic
with the metaphor being that they are
the musical performers and the set list
of songs are their net abilities and
cerebellum's you in particular is quite
interesting preferring the group before
it has this established style and also
not wanting others to barge in which
could be a reference to Nobunaga and
Henry in the current situation or
potentially even morena's plans to
recruit new members but it was so one
for one that I thought that the Haley
family were actually speaking in code
for a second like registering that yes
other people are listening so we're
gonna continue our strategic
conversation just you know and some some
code yeah I really didn't say that right
but I am not really recording it however
I think I gave the Haley family far far
too much credit as the chapter unfolded
I think it's pretty evident that there
was no real plan or trap in place to
deal with no banaka and Henry at least
not from this particular part of Haley
members they were very much just
legitimately hanging out in the base
filled with confidence that their
defense systems were Nyan perfect which
is a very unearned confidence what
happened in this chapter was probably
the best case scenario for everyone
involved no binagra and Henry they got
some information deposited the
transmitter and then even returned
unscathed meanwhile the Hayley family
got extraordinarily lucky that the
people who came after them had these
extraordinarily straightforward
abilities that they could kind of
improvise around because there are a lot
of other troop members who would have
felt a bit dirty after all of this
hisoka searching and just decided to
take a Haley bloodbath and I think it
shows that this family is still far too
ignorant of the world of nen because
even with their pretty damn cool and in
one case insane inability what happened
here was essentially two groups playing
rock paper scissors and resulting in a
draw by the way I just want you to know
how much it pains me to say rock paper
scissors in Australia we say he say
scissors paper rock but I can't say that
because then the comments get flooded
with Americans going
you know what you all sound like our
first new net ability of the chapter is
rather delightfully called sweet home
and it belongs to terebellum it's a very
cool Power actually I like it a lot and
it transfers damage taken by terebellum
to anything being touched by his left
hand and I think it was superbly
aesthetically introduced with fantastic
artwork of the knife in the head in
addition to that he can also straight up
transfer the damage of others by
touching them with his right hand and
transferring the damage again through
the object in his left hand object or
person person as well I imagine this
could work out very terribly for someone
but both hands need to be making contact
with their respective targets at the
time of impact so it's a power that can
make you practically invulnerable but it
is very very finicky to use and it also
seems to operate with a similar
principle to vacante's Door power which
makes sense because both for Conte and
cerebellum are emitters but one way way
you can think about it is that
cerebellum does what vacante does except
that cerebellum transports damage to a
new location overall it's the same
general principle of teleportation just
applied in a different way and part of a
now Trend with the Haley family
considering that luini was also an
emitter who found an ability based in
teleportation it's almost like whoever
developed the teleportation power first
set a trend and then the other Haley
emitters put their own unique spinner
because up until this point we've only
rarely seen a mission used in this sort
of way two examples I could think of off
the top of my head would be nov's hide
and seek obviously novel is an emitter
and also layario's remote punch that
operates on a similar principle I
suppose but again they are rare cases of
a mission being used in this way and now
we have the sudden huge concentration of
emissive teleportation sort of like a
niche cultural development but sweet
home in particular does give us some
fascinating insight into the personality
of terabella this is definitely not the
sort of power I'd expected of him given
his background as a Hitman and
especially combining that with a mission
I would have thought that he would have
developed a much more offensive heart
but it looks like his innate nature is
more one of self-preservation but also
showing that yeah he does have a genuine
care for those around him to some degree
at least terebellum isn't the selfish
kind of yes all for me and none for not
me kind of guy that we're kind of used
to with the Haley family because that's
what luini and forget the other guy's
name the guy who turned his arm into
weapons and then died and just doesn't
matter anymore but it looks like there's
a lot more going on with terabellum and
I am quite pleased by that and this goes
even further with yokitani who has one
of my favorite inabilities introduced in
this entire rock called lsdf most attack
and there's a bit to break down here the
lsdf acronym is likely a reference to
the jsdf the Japan special Defense
Forces I suppose in this case the L
might stand for legal but also probably
not because I don't tend to assume that
tagashi is invoking English meanwhile
moist refers to the philosophy that a
person should care equally for all
regardless of relationship even if that
relationship is one of hostility hence
why this whole event was resolved quite
peacefully but this hatsu has everything
I love about net which is simple idea
Plus complex conditions equals
ridiculously specific and odd power and
I should say that I've seen some people
complaining about how easily Nobunaga
was dealt with by yokitani but let me
tell you the and King marowam himself
would not have been able to destroy
these Den guards if he met their
conditions just like how he wasn't able
to destroy Knuckles APR speaking of
knuckle and yokitani's powers are quite
similar to one another because both
prefer the path of pacifism these
abilities are crafted with the idea of
an invincible nenbeast that deals with
opponents without causing them any
physical harm with that said yokitani's
ability is in a whole league of its own
and it's because of the like gazillion
restrictions required to actually use it
in order to summon and wheel these here
Jolly Bad Boys yokitani himself needs to
be within the Haley base as does Morena
which is a big problem because it's
never a good idea to tie your personal
inability to a completely separate
individual yokitani also needs to
introduce himself meaning that a
particularly bloodthirsty opponent could
have the opportunity to kill him before
the ability activates and in addition to
that the target needs to have committed
a crime before the guards will actually
do anything so if you're keeping score
that is four conditions that yokitani
needs to meet before anything happens
which is the same number of conditions
that crawler needs to satisfy to you
skill Hunter so this is it's an
unusually complex power for an amateur
to the point where I highly doubt that
this was developed by yokitani in
isolation I suspect that Morena had a
very strong hand in guiding yokitani to
this solution here's a scary thing
though the potential of this ability has
really only just begun to be explored
the last time we were updated yokitani
was a level 27 meaning that we have at
least another 73 levels of potential
development available for what is
already a pretty damn ridiculous power
when used correctly which so far it is
for the most part I mean it's very
difficult to actually attack yokitani
before he introduces himself because he
can't step through the doorway without
being teleported back to the original
room which is where Henry and urbanago
sent back to at the end meanwhile
projectile attacks can work but not
while cerebellum is there to absorb them
so it's it's quite tricky for more
precise menus users I suppose what you
would need is someone with just a much
more explosively packed projectile power
we also receive a glimpse into the
powers of two more Haley members one of
which is orage who blocks a knife with a
copy of weekly Shonen Jump which is the
magazine Hunter Hunter is published in
and I'm not sure but this might be Luffy
from one piece on the cover that might
just be my eyes and my own fictional
pirate personal bias but what I see
right there is a rubber man with a straw
hat behind him and on another note I
can't believe that I'm starting to
seriously learn the names of all of
these guys but orega's Affinity is
currently unknown he could just be using
basic enhancement on the magazine to
block the knife although to be honest I
think a copy of weekly Shonen Jump is so
thick with so many C's that it could
just block any knife without men but the
reason why the jump was used was for the
much more intriguing character of
pedagor who wanted to purposely get hit
by the knife in order to activate his
own ability again with paragord we have
yet to discover his net Affinity in fact
the last time we checked he was only a
level 18 which means he's killed at
least three more people between now and
then to help level up to the point where
he actually has an ability early family
have been busy and it seems to be
implied that he has some sort of healing
powers because he wants to test himself
damage wise but the much more shiny and
nugget here is paragord's designation as
the organ Moreno has chosen him for this
seemingly important role and if I had to
guess right now it may be a condition
for a larger ability say in order to
maintain the nen structure of The
Hideout one person needs to be
designated as the key organ which
paragord would be quite suited to if he
does have a healing ability but then
again it also might be a phantom troop
style situation A metaphorical
designation of yes you are the organ you
are the muscles I am the head you know
it's something organizational like that
but probably not I think it has more to
do with magic powers but again I think
this chapter worked out far better than
Nobunaga and Henry could have hoped for
they now have information they have a
tracking device that the actual physical
location of the bass and in addition to
all of that they are both perfectly safe
the only issue is that Nobunaga had his
Katana confiscated which interestingly
enough needing to retrieve his sword is
how we got into to this whole Mafia mess
to begin with I don't think that he's
defenseless or more importantly
attackless without it but if it wasn't
important then he probably wouldn't have
gone to Such Great Lengths to retrieve
it in the first place so as much as I
did bring the sigh of relief at the end
Nobunaga does still feel a little bit
vulnerable right now because being at
anything less than 100 could be a
potential death sentence when trapped on
a ship populated by an increasingly
powerful net Mafia a devastating set of
nen princes and of course when one is
being specifically targeted by the
illustrious murder clown himself